kapow saturday is free comic book day
and here to tell us more about this
christmas for comic book lovers is jay
bosworth with maximum comics it's great
to see you again buddy good to see you
jc thanks for having me back yeah so
what's taking place tomorrow the biggest
day of the year if you're a comic book
person free comic book day how exciting
isn't that it's a great day it's like
christmas for comic book readers yeah if
you like comics or you're a reader or
anything tomorrow's the day you've been
waiting for all year long and this is a
great day to bring new readers into
comics as well and what are some of the
books that you guys have featured
absolutely so there's free stuff that we
will have at the stores tomorrow truly
free we've got uh marvel has a
spider-man venom book um voices which is
really great they're lgtbq characters
and creators uh they're less represented
characters and creators all in one book
for free um we've got dc super pets
which is great and the justice league
with a shiny shiny comic cover who
doesn't love that these are all free
tomorrow those are free yes those books
right there are free tomorrow walk into
the store get there early you have x
amount to give away tomorrow yep and
just hand out free comic books it's a
nationwide event every good comic book
store in the country will be
participating in this and you're one of
the best and what i like about jay is
you you go like go a lot you get dressed
up tomorrow you're going to be dr
strangelove
that's the movie
busted i will be doctor strange tomorrow
yes that will be doctor strange dr
strange the biggest movie of the weekend
but uh yes doctor strange will be there
amongst other superheroes uh
stormtroopers from star wars lots of
characters spiderman will be there lots
of characters at both of our shops now
you have
also about your story it's more than
just comic books yeah so right here we
have from dr strange you have some funko
pops here yeah funkos are huge uh funkos
everyone's into funkos
they're odd looking little characters
but we've got spider-man and doctor
strange here we've got a scarlet witch
figure on the more collectible side of
things um
fun little tchotchkes and things yeah
and this one here this this this one i
do the rock does the voice in this movie
right yes yeah i know my stuff i know my
stuff you also have some really
exclusive comics at your store we do
there's free and then there's not free
comic books there's the more collectible
kind the more valuable kind the kind you
invest more in let's talk about you
brought two of those show us what you
have here so black panther we all know
that uh chad boseman passed away
recently and marvel said they're not
going to recast them but interestingly
enough in the comics um hopefully that's
not too shiny uh they just came out with
let's see if i get there you go this
introduces a new character who they're
teasing potentially could be the new
black panther and this has been graded
so we that can't be opened it's a
collectible issue right wow and this one
here as well what's this other special
one that you have biggest show the last
few weeks has been moon night and um
this introduces the brand new character
one of the new moon knight characters um
on the show in this comic book so people
are crazy about moon moon night right
now for good reason jay i love your
passion for comics how much is something
like i'm holding in my hands how much
9.6 creating right now how much is
something like this work so it came out
when it came out it was 3.99
graded at that point that's you're right
around two to three hundred dollars
right now wow only go up as the
character gets older and increases and
we see him more and more in movies i
remember hearing just last year the
superman issue number one sold for like
2.5 million dollars people like wow i
finally had that here's the thing though
back when superman one came out it was
worth a nickel yeah you get these comic
books for free tomorrow and some of
these might go up in value you never
know so i will tell you a spoiler alert
there is a marvel book out tomorrow with
the eternals in it and it's the first
appearance of blade the vampires hunter
blade the vampire hunter's daughter
people are already calling us they want
it like crazy it's free
get it and grade it put it away and it
will be a valuable book because blade is
about to be popping in the marvel movies
too i love it i love is that is it one
of them here here i do have it uh bright
i wanted to hide it yeah so it's the
x-men versus the avengers versus the
eternals and it introduces blade's
daughter wow for free jay thank you so
much real quick what's the website cause
you have multiple stores inside
maximumcomics.com awesome rocky i'll
send it over to you wow that was great
information thanks guys